[Music]
forgot the training news Oh submitted by
Chad Sioux passengers are claiming that
the crew of an AirAsia flight caused a
panic by screaming as their plane
plummeted 20,000 feet wide attendant
scream the crew and the [ __ ] captain
came out I'm always like and then it's
they're like chillin I'm like okay good
that's 100% true because he was so
shocked by the news you got a [ __ ]
over Saul in there he's gonna spit the
water oh my god I imagined them all
coming out like I soon as the plane
started plummeting they're like grabbing
their parachutes like all right Joe yes
where is it damn it I forgot it's a
hundred percent true no Saul yeah it's
100% true because when the you know
there's like points where everything
shakes on Matt scared of heights
yeah but as long as the the attendant is
doing this while he's shaking you know
when it comes up but the face is still
still yeah boom this are knocking [ __ ]
down would you like some water yeah cuz
they're falling everyone but their faces
they're used to this [ __ ] yeah
so when I see that and I'm like I'm like
nervous and then I see that I'm like
okay if they're not tripping then I got
nothing to trip about yeah I got one I
would be like oh my god well I sleep
through all turbulence I just sleep
because I feel like I don't get the
butterflies when I think I'm asleep you
know I'm saying like it wakes me up
I don't know as always I just I don't
think I'm I don't think I'm gonna die
ever
I feel like me am i I've had the worst
time sleeping on planes ever since I
took business International because that
[ __ ] spoiled my [ __ ] ass and I have a
standard for what sleep is mm-hmm now I
can't sleep on regular seats they
[ __ ] sucked
you should try AirAsia seat that stuff
is I feel like I'm too big for it
it's like a big give you the whole case
like you by yourself you [ __ ] yes the
AirAsia seats are really small area
which country cuz I be I'll be comfy in
all my seats as long as I get my windows
I guess so [ __ ] mad like my my
girlfriend she does left the whole
Indian Lake crossing on her chair her
[Applause]
complaint is that she just she needs a
footrest oh she could keep her legs up
cuz they're too short like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Wow over here suffering dude the
time at asleep between sit between you
two
oh I was gonna shoot myself dude she
came out like 10 pounds thinner because
of the sauna in between see being tall
is whack man so I'm trying to tell y'all
it wasn't the high okay the high kind of
sucks but it's the wind between these
two it's the width they like bleed over
onto my seat I'm just like this like you
were just getting hugged for 10 hours
quit trippin dude was affectionate love
language all right so this flights left
Perth Australia at 11:15 a.m. for Bali
Indonesia right so about an hour into
the flight that's when the the plane
somehow lost cabin pressure and so
somehow yeah somehow I don't know how I
lost cabin pressure and then all of the
math things came down oh my god that
would freak me the [ __ ] like passengers
on this flight we're saying that like
everyone was cool we're just like
alright we got to do this we're cool but
then the flight crew started like
panicking on the on the thingy
because it had to go they're all going
to die
no family member so what happens when
having pressure when when they look
cabin pressure the immediate protocol is
to lower the aircraft so it was around
34,000 feet up in the air and it
plummeted 20,000 feet down to compensate
for that I could be at a breathable air
yeah when you say plummeted what is that
like you just like yes specifically I
see like we Shh yeah well the the pilots
they're the ones that were like making
sure that the entire aircraft goes down
and then quicker so that's like some
elevator feeling [ __ ] oh my god they're
just doing their job that's when your
[ __ ] goes up to your guts they're
saying that they did that that drop in a
matter of minutes so I guess it wasn't
like seconds where it was like 20,000
feet
that's called g-force anal mm-hmm sounds
like a mature so then the flight crew
started screaming alright ordering
people to get down instead of using a
calmer tone yeah they were just like
yeah and then so the thing is too that
this airline is from Indonesia they
played all like the emergency [ __ ] in
Indonesian or what's their language yeah
yes Indonesian Indonesian so then people
were like we don't understand what's
happening or what they're saying that's
the craziest sounding language too by
the way it's like Vietnamese and to
Golic put together like if they say if
you watch any Indonesian film it'll be
like and it just says hello
it is like one [ __ ] word I don't know
why the language is so [ __ ] insane
the sounds like I'll SWAT me one
passenger said this quote the panic was
escalated because because of the
behavior of the staff who were screaming
and looked tearful and shot always we
look to them for reassurance
we didn't get any we were more worried
because of how panic of course so the
passengers were having to calm down the
Stewart because then this other
passenger said that the the crew was
they went hysterical there was no real
panic before that I just put your like
like - like crew cabin members look you
start [ __ ] each other I just finish
the flatlands changing out of the
uniform into regular clothes damn he
planned this a little bit ahead of time
that's another whole complete thing is
based on the fact that Air Asia is not
training their crew properly like a
common procedure it's vomiting [ __ ]
20,000 yeah if the cabin loses pressure
it's common practice to make sure to
plummet the to a more breathable there
any like plummet free flights cuz I'm a
daughter I don't want to go any plumbing
place so I make sure you guys a clip so
we recorded it it's 16 seconds and it's
really bad quality really bad quality
warning you oh my gosh yes oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it was sad too because it was one
woman saying like she said she tried
sending a text her family everyone
thought they were gonna die oh [ __ ] oh
that's like that couple in Titanic that
like as the water they're cuddling as
the water is coming up over the bed this
[ __ ] reminds me of lost you know with
the plane [ __ ] crashes and [ __ ]
nobody else watch that bad show yeah you
know it was good for a couple seasons
yeah I watched it all over again and I
was like oh man this is a good show then
see the three hit I was like yeah she
got weird
we could have saved the show after the
third c-axis writer strike yeah they
ruined it you never hold me if we have a
plummeting flight okay I'm gonna crawl
up a man if I thought I was gonna die
I'm taking I'm like yo let's go to the
bathroom we're going out on the
mile-high club I wanna see the crash
landing and this is your corpse and a
girl you like because we have class G oh
that's one I didn't say that he said
though class what are all the corpses
clothed their separate Timothy
DeLaGhetto
where he's just like this things happen
they're used either taking a [ __ ] or
[ __ ] yeah you need to dig up knowing
you're about to die adrenaline all the
blood all the Bloods rushing that be so
funny you get to put it he just have
your finger in there like this and
somehow he flew right into her [ __ ] my
god on impact
Oh were the only ones that survived walk
out of a baboon like Megan and
everyone's dead like uh so that's the
secret yeah all the court I was used to
be cracking up we're stuck to the
ceilings is dead and naked the only two
naked people have the flight five
hundred years from now people are gonna
investigate the plane crash and it's
gonna be all petrified people and [ __ ]
and you and she is gonna be like in this
position with your pants around your
ankles though the pad survived
what but yeah so it was there are 145
passengers on this flight but luckily
they were able so they ended up turning
back around and they landed in Perth
safely and everyone was just like
cheering and but yeah the main thing was
the fact that the crew just are freaking
the [ __ ] out I don't know if they even
had training on a cabin being at losing
pressure what is the decompression yes
exactly yeah the whole thing is that the
crew didn't get trained and it was kind
of [ __ ] up for the passengers because
they look to them for right yeah all
they did was cause more panic and more
fear into these patient passengers when
you showed us the video I was expecting
for flight attention should be running
up and down the aisle just [ __ ]
screaming yeah I thought I don't want
any screams I didn't do that
have y'all ever seen the movie airplane
yeah oh it's like that oh it's from like
the 70s yeah okay so there's a movie
called airplane and it's about like a
plane that's gonna crash right so
there's anyways there's one seed it's so
random this let's see where everybody's
like screaming in the plane and running
back and forth and then like I don't
know where you just a Nikki girl just
jumping from the camera you see her
boobs bounce like two seconds and that's
like titties in calories for no reason
it was a director's perverted like idea
maybe that's where the phrase calm your
tits come from , calm your tits
calm your tits I love airplanes by the
way I don't care cuz I'm gonna die
anyway that is how I live [ __ ]
i'ma die anyway might as well try today
I'm like imma die anyway might as well
try today Joe was on the plane with his
phone on during landing and his seats
reclined all the way back yup it's
living life on the edge whenever they
tell me to put it on airplane mode I'm
like [ __ ] that thanks for watching guys
and those are our thoughts what are your
thoughts don't forget to comment below
we want to know what you guys are
thinking but don't write anything that
will make it sad or make us mad because
after all we're just kidding news and
we're a very happy channel for the last
video click up here
you